after years of waiting a sequel to Tron
has finally come it's Tron Legacy the
reaction to this film seemed to be very
split and it seemed to be with very
specific people anyone that was waiting
for years and years to see sequel to
Tron usually don't like it but the
typical movie goer just looking to have
a good time with some okay effects in
action seem to like it fine and seeing
how I never got that big into Tron to
begin with yeah I guess I'm on that boat
too the setup is years later Flynn's son
is the CEO of a gigantic corporation but
he's also a lost rebel that likes to
sabotage his own corporation yeah try to
make sense out of that he's upset
because he could never find out what
happened to his father but suddenly all
his questions are answered when he
himself is sucked into the video game
world he finds what he thinks is his
father but honestly it's just a
look-alike all the CLU the CEO you of
course wants control of everything and
wants to keep Flynn as far away from it
as possible so just as he's about to ex
Flynn son Flynn's apprentice comes in
and saves the day reuniting the son with
the father and here's where it gets
confusing and complicated again I guess
the reason that all this happened is
because Flynn while staying in the
program discovered some form of life
that created itself and apparently has
all the answers to life the universe
religion all that stuff this is what
caused the big split between Flynn and
the CLU and the race is on to who can
have total control of everything to take
over the world or something like that
like I said it gets weird and
complicated and let's face it that's not
the kind of movie this is this movie is
here to be a straightforward
action-adventure with cool effects and a
unique design and yeah that's pretty
much what we got I give it credit for
tapping on some of these ideas but they
don't really follow all the way through
with it or if they do it's in a story
that's way too complicated to understand
I guess in a way it is very much like
the first one as it is hard to follow
but with the first one it was tied in
much more to the story on what was going
on here it's just sort of more of a side
event while the rest of the movie is
busy making excuses to have fights
but they're fun fight sequences and
there's a lot of great visuals is a
great action no but I will give a credit
for having a very unique design that
adds on top of the original tron film
you do look at this universe a yes this
is still Tron but at the same time
they've really updated it
it isn't just cleaning up the effects it
is still giving it its very unique look
like if you were to put on Tron and then
Tron Legacy you could clearly tell which
one was which so for me I think the film
is OK
I wasn't expecting much and I got
actually a little bit more than I
expected at least with the visuals in
the action but anyone hoping for some
sort of groundbreaking film or the
sequel you've been waiting years and
used to continue the grand story and
answer a lot of the questions you're not
gonna get it here this is a punch amount
movie with some nice effects and one or
two ideas are just sort of tapped upon
so hopefully you can figure out if
they'll be to your liking and you can
see for yourself